foreign
big beautiful British Columbia and my
life is fueled by exploring nature both
at home and around the world in fact
this is from the Himalaya just a few
months ago when I was climbing there
nature is a huge part of my life and it
inspires my creative and professional
world as well I work hard with my team
inspired by nature in in Vancouver
designing buildings as an architecture
practice we have two main missions our
first mission is to focus on making
beautiful buildings that serve our
community and respond to the needs of
the people within them the second
mission we have is focused on the fact
that the first mission has a huge impact
on the planet and on climate change and
we have to work to reduce it as a result
our firm is often called a highly
sustainable practice
and the truth is it really isn't in fact
I don't believe that word Sustainable
Building or sustainable practice is
really true in most cases and the reason
is the built environment uses enormous
amount of the world's resources and far
too few of those come from renewable
resources
in fact the vast majority of the
material that man makes on earth goes
into the built environment the other
challenge with buildings is they
represent about 39 percent of our
greenhouse gas emissions or in North
America almost half of our greenhouse
gas emissions for reference because it's
not talked about enough all of cars
planes automobiles the entire
Transportation sector combined represent
only about 23 percent so buildings are a
huge part of the problem and not
discussed enough
the reason for that are both the heating
and cooling of buildings of course but
also the materials that go into building
so when it comes to materials the
building structures what holds the
buildings up really are composed of four
major materials in every city on the
planet concrete steel masonry and wood
and of those four materials three of
them have very very high carbon
Footprints in particular concrete and
steel now wood is the only material on
that list that's also a renewable
resource and sequesters carbon so it's
the only pathway as a material that
actually can get us to carbon neutral
buildings and it's the pathway we choose
in our practice to build all buildings
so our practice has been a Timber only
practice since our Inception and as part
of our advocacy for the use of wood and
buildings about 15 years ago I wrote a
book called the case for Tallwood
buildings and that book taught the
lesson of why we should do this and how
we should do this and in the beginning
it was a very unlikely concept that
people had a hard time believing giving
and yes we figured out that we could
have built the Empire State Building
entirely out of wood that early idea now
is a mainstream concept around the world
and in Sustainable Building practices
and there are hundreds of Tallwood
buildings that have either been built or
currently under design and construction
and thousands more to come
the wood as a sustainable idea is not
sustainable unless it actually comes
from sustainable Forest practices and
much of the planet has forests that we
actually need to keep standing as part
of our climate solution and in fact lots
of the world have forests that are under
deep threat if we think about where
population in the world mostly resides
and where it's growing the quickest in
fact most of those areas either don't
have forest or also aware these forests
are threatened and so wood is good a
solution as it is and a solution that I
still very much believe in is not a
global solution most of our cities are
still built in those first three
materials steel concrete and masonry and
they have a high carbon footprint we're
working hard and people are working hard
to make concrete and steal better but
unfortunately tweaking those existing
materials is making them only modestly
better in the case of concrete it's
estimated they can reduce the carbon
footprint of concrete at best between 10
and 35 percent and that's a long way to
go from where we need to be either at
Carbon neutrality in our cities are
better yet and carbon sequestering
carbon negative buildings so how do we
get there after building about a million
and a half square feet of mass Timber I
still believe in that material but I
keep asking myself this question what is
the alternative to the Big Four
and the answer in my mind without
question is studying and understanding
what's happening in nature and Nature's
structures combining that with modern
biotechnology and combining that with
all of the computer modeling that allows
us to make incredibly efficient
structures going forward all those
things together are creating what we
call five five is a fifth way a new
structural material that will replace in
my mind over time the Big Four
it's an all-organic material made from
forests and crops that can be grown all
over the world
strong and safe and it eventually will
be cost effective and competitive
against any other material available
this isn't a new idea products made from
natural materials thankfully are growing
up everywhere there's a huge industry of
biomaterials and Academia as well as in
private business and we're seeing new
products come online every day this
community is strong and hopefully
getting stronger and our contribution to
it is really focused on this idea of the
biggest material use which again is the
building's structure
so how does it work so the idea is based
on the same concept of how a tree works
or any other vascular plant as we zoom
in a tree is sort of made of lignified
tissues that go from the bottom of the
tree to the top as our plants and those
ligophied tissues have within them in
the cell structure cellulose fibers and
lignin that together make the plants
strong in order to grow and Thrive and
those two materials the fiber in the
plant as well as the lignin as well as
other binders make up the ingredients of
what we call five
studying the fibers and how they work in
plants is another part of how we're
trying to make this structure and if we
all imagine cutting through a branch as
the image just showed we know that
nature finds very efficient ways to
create structures and they're often
round like a branch
but as humans we tend to make boxy
structures
and and the reason we do that is
concrete Steel in these materials in
Wood are more efficient when we form
them as a box or when we cut them as a
box it's more affordable and that's why
we see it so a typical structure has
columns and beams and a slab to make it
up
and they're very boxy forms as you can
see in the image now different
structures behave very differently all
the time this particular structure is an
example from a tall building but if we
were talking about a house of the
different structure or if we're talking
about a hockey rink it would be another
structure so just in this example how do
the forces work well you have the force
of the way to people and you have the
force of the weight of the building
above you have wind blowing on the sides
or an earthquake impacting it the forces
as they press down on this particular
example in blue are forces of
compression that's the squeezing forces
pushing down the forces here in yellow
are the tension forces the pulling apart
on that structure when we put those
together we see how the forces move to
the ground through this simple frame and
it's sort of a flowing diagram
in fact when we use what's called a
structural stress plot you can see that
the form is very natural in its
character but as I said we build things
out of boxes and when we overlap in our
example a boxy structure of wood for
example we see these areas in red which
really are unnecessary they're wasted
material in the current way we build in
this example working with our Engineers
we actually calculated that this
particular example would result in about
27 percent material waste now all
buildings are different it's very hard
to make it sort of overall calculation
some buildings more efficient some less
efficient but if we multiplied this by
the amount of building that needs to be
built over the next 40 years for
Humanity it's an incredible amount of
human waste
and poor use of our resources
so our goal with five is how do we use
as little resources as possible and when
you use little resources in a building
or you lighten the building up
and a lighter building actually means
that it weighs less on the ground and
our foundations below the ground can be
lighter as well
so less resources equals lighter
buildings equals even less resources
taking this idea of how five can use
less we took four existing known
Solutions and put them together the
first is we take those plant fibers I
described and that can come from trees
that can come from plants grass bamboo
it can come from waste Wood Products it
can come from clearing the understory of
a forest to make it less likely for
forest fire in places like California we
take those fibers and combine them with
other organic binders and lignin in
order to sort of create a solid product
and then we take these computer models
that allow us to really design
efficiency into the way we build so we
can boil out all that waste and then
finally we're going to use custom
robotics that means that every part of a
building rather than being cookie cutter
and the same and wasteful can be just as
much material as needed and no more in
order to make the building safe together
that makes something that looks like
this and again this is an example the
Flat Top is flat because we walk on
Floors but underneath Building looks
more organic in its shape and as you can
see these beams and columns feel a
little bit more like branches and more
like what we see in nature as we zoom in
even further we start to see how it's
actually composed and you may think in
your mind as this fiberboard is this
particle board things you've seen before
well actually what we're talking about
is a very microscopic layering of these
plant fibers they're just a millimeter
long by laying them together and cross
laminating them across each other we can
customize the way based again on the
structural model exactly how the
compensation of each piece of the
material Works in order to make it as
efficient as possible we combine it with
these organic polymers and and lignin
and ultimately make this material a
strong dense and behaves much like a
tree one now we do that in another
unique way and the way the forming work
works because no pieces of a structure
have to be the same and we want to
reduce waste we use robotic forms and
fabric forms the red is fabric that
moves in and out and allows each piece
of the building to be completely
uniquely customizable and again we're
using it to reduce the waste of a
structure
now when we put that all together it
looks like something completely
different something that none of us have
seen before it's not like steel it's not
like concrete and it's not like wood
instead in this example what you see is
an entirely plant-based structure
it's healthy and beautiful to be around
its shapes are not there as decoration
they're there as just structural
Essentials and yet they're beautiful
it's safe to be within it sequesters
carbon so it's part of our solution for
climate change
I believe we cannot continue to work
with broken systems and try to make them
better we have to imagine something next
we also can't wait for the world's
resources to run out before we imagine a
future that's different
we are no longer part of an industrial
revolution of materials we're at the
beginning of Mother Nature's revolution
of materials
as a result
we can make much more beautiful
environments for everyone
as I walk around the forest of my home
and I look at up into the trees and
imagine what the buildings of the future
are
I imagine that they'll use less
resources they'll have less impact they
will still make strong healthy
communities for all of us
but they'll do so more efficiently
all of these ideas are ideas that
already exist there's nothing new here
we have an opportunity to live in a
completely biological world we just have
to decide to so
there's a community growing of companies
and products of biomaterials that are
available and every day there are new
materials introduced into the system we
can and we will solve this combination
of human need and the planet's need at
the same time
all we need to do is listen to Nature
and let her teach us how
thank you
[Music]